she was in the peace corps in ecuador
and she's a banana bread master and her
side gig is painting and she is actually
one of our artists
who donated paintings so everyone please
welcome selena to the stage
thank you jared for that great
introduction it's great to be here
thank you so much for inviting me again
uh to the our conference i absolutely
love this conference it's so
much fun and um i have here the
uh nerdy outlet nerdy slash artsy outlet
i
am into lately which is this r plate and
it's
it's very durable actually it's pretty
you know
sturdy and thick it um it's microwavable
and you can wash it you put water on it
so it's great for serving cheese and
grapes with your wine
to talk about your your stats with your
friends
so so that's a good fun outlet for me
and so today i'm going to talk about
a project we have at my work i'm a data
scientist at the inter-american
development bank
you can see my twitter handle um
on the screen and our project is called
predicting delays
at the inter-american development bank
using r
uh please note this is my own
presentation um done in my own capacity
these are my opinions and not those
of the idb
so a little background again i was
talking about how much i love art
it's um just one of my hobbies and
um i did our pumpkin a while back i had
our cupcakes for one of my
um training sessions in r and
um of course the r plate which is up for
auction
i'd like to introduce my team first me
um i'm originally from maine um and
that's a picture of me with lasers in
the background of course
marcelo carrillo is my colleague at the
idb he's originally from ecuador he's an
amazing programmer
alexis estevez is also at the idb he's
originally from
argentina and he's a great data
scientist
and pablo reba also my colleague he's
from costa rica he's really good at the
business side and the data architecture
management
and finally dr jonathan hirsch who is
our external consultant from chapman
university
this this is john in the chess club
and his earlier days let's get a
close-up that's him let's get a close-up
absorb absorb it because he don't
recognize him
this is him today
so that's our great team so here's the
overview
um this by the way this presentation has
a lot of animations in it i kind of went
crazy with that so
brace yourselves um i also try to make
it somewhat interactive
so there are two parts the first part is
we'll look at
what is the model so we'll think about
the business need the data
the model itself the challenges and the
results
and finally do managers trust the model
it turns out this is a very frontier
topic so we'll look at some other cases
so what's the business need the
inter-american development bank where i
work
um it is the leading source of
development financing for latin america
in the caribbean
with 26 borrowing member countries which
are in green
at the right uh the idb offers loans
grants and technical assistance to
governments
it aims to reduce poverty and inequality
and its main instrument is called
sovereign guaranteed investment loans
basically that just means the idb gives
loans directly to
uh governments so a little bit about
sg loans the average loan size is 67
million dollars
so that's pretty big i mean we're
dealing with large infrastructure
projects or major overhauls to a road
system or
to a um environmental management system
um the loans can go as big as 150
million or small as 25 million
around 90 new loans are approved every
year
and at any given point in time there's
around 500 loans in execution
by the ibb so an example project would
be like
a hydroelectric dam um in this case this
is a regional project so
several country governments are involved
and the total cost is 80 million dollars
so as you can imagine this is a big
project with lots of actors and
components
and it's going to take some time to
execute um
typically the projects are designed to
execute within five years
so that's five years to disburse all 80
million dollars or a hundred percent of
the funds
so what do you think a delay means well
a delay at the id
at the idv means for whatever reason
the idd could not disperse 100 of the
funds
so that might happen for various reasons
um it's not that the idb doesn't have
the money it's because
something happened at the project level
on the grounds that made it
delayed and therefore the next milestone
or the next tranche of
funds could not be dispersed so
think to yourselves what percent of sg
loans do you think are delayed what's
what's the scope here um
is it five percent 20 50 percent well
78 of sg loans approved since 2000
have some sort of delay oops that's kind
of a large number
um what do you think the average delay
is
it's 14 months so over a year so instead
of that five year window
projects tend to have extensions to
their original deadline
of five years so there's something going
on here with the design of projects
that causes these delays to happen
moreover
33 percent of projects had extensions
over two years
so that's a big deal so you're at the
right you can see a breakdown of
of the situation where only 22 percent
of projects are on time and
a third are significantly delayed
so what is the implication for the bank
how much do you think the idb spent on
supervising these extended loans
over an eight year period 50 million
dollars
so that's around six or seven million
dollars a year that the idb is spending
to deal with these late loans
so those late loans cost around sixty
percent more on average than on time
projects
so as you can see this is a problem for
the organization
in terms of cost and also in terms of
the development goals for the country
if you're curious about the breakdown of
the delays then by country then
this is the map that shows you also made
in
um r so mexico uh
the blue means the the projects are on
time or early so a lot of
uh proportion of mexico's projects are
earlier on time
whereas yellow and orange mean there's a
larger delay
so guatemala and brazil maybe argentina
those are having those are countries
where a lot of projects
um have a larger average delay
so what's our objective here first of
all
we need to predict the delays why do we
do that because we need to help managers
develop a proactive approach
to avoid the delays second they need to
know in real time
they need to know the risk of delays
before they happen and ideally as soon
as a project is approved
so right when the project is born by the
idb we need to have an idea
based on historic data of how long the
project will last
and this information should be updated
every month
finally we need a clear visualization we
make a dashboard
so that end users can see the results in
a simple way
so here's another one of my art outlets
i made this schematic
of the data pipeline if you will
for the project for the modeling process
so the first stage is the data itself
and in our case we have lots of
different data sources we have the
company data we have
lots of structured data we have the
funky data
which requires more cleaning and then
there's always cool data we wish we
had but we can't use for some reason
so what's the data we're using well we
just threw in
as much as you could possibly figure out
from
use from our company system so here's
just a giant list of everything we're
using and there's over 100
features and we're still adding more so
we have fixed variables which is the
dark blue so you have things like the
country of the loan the department
the approval year the approved amount
and then you have dynamic variables
things that change over time so things
like the number of changes in the team
leader
is there a high rotation in the
management
team of the of the project um how much
experience does the team know there have
things like that um obviously this is
going to be a nightmare as a data
scientist and
someone who has to deal with this data
because not only do you have to clean
the data once you have to make
scripts that are flexible enough and
robust
to slight changes in the underlying data
structure so you need to make a flexible
pipeline so that
one tiny little data error doesn't blow
up the entire model
so the next phase is data cleaning
so what do we do we have the outcome we
have a bunch of features
and we want to make a model from those
features that predict the outcome
and then we're going to use the same
model to predict
onto projects where we don't know the
outcome that's the goal
so this is actually non-trivial how do
we set up
the actual data itself for the model
what we decided to do was create a long
format
where every row is a
month of the project's age and then the
project itself
so each row represents the month
age of the project and then of course
the outcome
is fixed and then the some features are
fixed and some features
are time varying one disadvantage to the
setup is obviously the rows
now are interdependent so for one
project
age to the next one time period to the
next obviously there's a lot of
um correlation among those rows that's
one disadvantage
of this setup but for now we're trying
to start with this is our baseline
and it's working pretty well so far and
we're gonna
try another phase where we fix those
problems
so next stage is what is the model
itself we want to do data exploration
and test
different uh ideas so
we have a lot of options we have um
a wish list on the left where you have a
bunch of different
features of models that you want
obviously we want the model to be
accurate
um we also want to have confidence
intervals around each prediction it
makes no sense to tell somebody the
project is going to be
delayed eight months and then not give
them some sort of
ballpark of how how um
you know what the range of possible
values is there
and then the next two boxes are the why
we want to be able to understand the
black box what are these
like predictions based on and you
want to have a way to kind of understand
that um
beyond just you know a clunky black box
model
you also want to have ideally a model
that runs pretty fast
and it needs to handle a large number of
variables
so of our candidate models it turns out
the random forest
is the most useful in our case although
it has the disadvantage of being
somewhat slow so the model itself takes
around
10 hours to run we do use a virtual
machine for that
so there's some architecture points that
you need to take into consideration when
you have a lot of data
we split the data into 85 for the
training and 15
for the testing the key our packages in
the model are
carrot and ranger and then we build
confidence intervals using
the infinitesimal jackknife approach
which is sort of like a fancy bootstrap
so now what are some of the challenges
in the actual
process of running the model this is the
data
cleaning pipeline so we have a ton of
data and a lot of our scripts and then
the model itself
is um its own beast so this is a lot to
manage
um so the key here is you have to
find a way to make that as simple as
possible
so what we did and what we recommend is
that you always have
one r script that's the master
control panel if you will for the rest
so if i want to run this model i just
start with
preparing the data which takes about 30
minutes
and the script goes through each of the
files that sources the cleaning
and then the second part is the model
itself
so the key is stay organized
you're gonna have to build a lot of
scripts and you're gonna have to
understand how they connect and then
other people have to figure that out too
someday so you're probably gonna have to
make a user manual
so that other people can figure it out
later so what are the results
so here's a predicted versus true plot
on the training set
so um on the x-axis it's the true
the true delay of the project in months
and on the y-axis is the prediction so
projects in the training set are
concentrated on the 45 degree line which
is good that's what we want to do
on the test set you can see that there's
a lot more dispersion
so that means we're over fit a little
bit um
in terms of the level of the error
if we look at the mean absolute error
it's really small for the
1.5 months on average is the difference
between the
um the the predicted delay and the true
delay whereas in the test set it's eight
months
um i think that's a that does show we
have we're over fit
but i don't think it's unreasonable to
say okay you're within
this range of you know your we know if
the projects would be significantly
delayed
or if it's just going to be sort of less
than or
you know if the level delay is less than
year so in my opinion
given the the fact that we're starting
with a baseline of zero
with no prediction at all i think this
is okay
um we're we're still refining the model
itself and adding new variables so
hopefully we'll get that
mean absolute error down for the test
set
so we have our results we have our model
we have our scripts
the next stage is to build a visual so
that other people can understand clearly
what's going on
so we do that in tableau um
we have here a dashboard that shows
everybody
what are the projects in execution what
is the age of that project and then what
is the
actual prediction which is the the dot
with the confidence intervals
and then of course people can filter by
region country
department anything they want you know
change the colors everything like that
and we also show people the performance
of the model on the test and training
set
so here's the predicted versus true um
uh plot where people can also manipulate
this and see how it changes by country
or their own division or department etc
so finally we we we do this and we
expose people to
the the final result and
the question is do managers trust the
model
well we ask them we sent a survey to
managers
in february of this year we got 87
responses
and the main question is after viewing
the prediction tool
did the decision tool alter your belief
in the likelihood of delay
however most managers did not update
their prediction of project delays
so you can see from this chart on the
right that if each dot
is a manager um their prediction of the
delay before
viewing the tool and then after is
almost
always the same so this is like
super upsetting because we want people
to change their beliefs that's the whole
point we want the ai to help them
know more than they already do so it
makes us
wonder if we did something wrong well it
turns out this is
not a trivial issue and um
it brings up the point of what's the
level of exposure
you let people see so at this point
we sort of hide this machine and then we
have this thing called the veil of data
ignorance
those are john's words and then
we can say okay well let's expose more
um and then let's let's just show them
the whole beast
i mean what's the level of control that
you
give the user so that they can
understand
what the actual model is um
and it turns out that's a very important
theme this is like
a frontier issue that we've just landed
upon
and um there's a lot of examples in in
the world
right now on this issue of trust in the
eye
so for example you know vehicle piloting
systems
are are people comfortable with letting
a car
drive them to somewhere or robotic
surgery
do doctors and patients trust a robot
more or a human more to
perform surgery robot warfare
do we trust a robot more than a human
and in sort of
the you know ethics of how to behave in
war uh if if we can call it that um
and then there's the famous jail times
um
case where you know judges are are given
an
ai model to predict whether or not a
defendant will reoffend if they're
released from jail
um and and what a lot of people found is
that you know
people often don't trust the ai tool so
we're trying to figure out why
um and a lot of times it's because
people see this noise
and they think it's the signal and we as
statisticians are
as data scientists we get noise we're
like oh that was just
this random thing we know randomness but
um
people in the real world these
experiences of seeing something happen
might not translate into a tool
you know that we want to be useful
so what things impact algorithmic trust
well according to abdullah al matuka mit
there's a lot of different things
transparency how well does the algorithm
work
interpretability can the model explain
its own decisions in a ways that humans
can understand performance is it
communicated well is it performing well
and control can the user actually modify
the algorithm
in our case i would say we fail in all
three except for one case
we do we do communicate the performance
well with our visual
but we're really not giving people very
much control and we're definitely not
letting them inside the black box of
this algorithm
so what we're planning on to do planning
on doing next is
giving them a little more uh insight
into this black box
so we're going to add these local
interpretability measures at the project
level where you can see
for example for this project um why does
the prediction
give us the result it does and it gives
you a breakdown by
um by variable it's not quite as
straightforward as saying a linear
regression model but
it gives you some insight into the black
box
of why a particular project has its
prediction
brighter model so what are the key
takeaways
first when designing a live prediction
model stay organized
make it flexible so one error doesn't
break the whole thing
and document your entire data flow so
this is the very
unsexy task of doing a user manual which
i always feel like i end up doing but it
has to be done
someone has to do it and then the next
question is
how do you lift the veil of data
ignorance
the interactive dashboard should mean
obviously filtering and changing colors
and downloading the final data like
that's what we think
interactive means but it should be so
much more than that
we should also be able to show the
influence of certain variables
on um on the model itself so give people
access to
what's going on at the variable level at
the feature
level and then let people manipulate the
input data
hopefully interactive means maybe they
can enter a fictitious project and then
they're going to see the result
based on them changing one variable at a
time
thank you very much
thank you selena uh excellent talk i
love the john hirsch references
uh those who don't know john hirsch gave
a workshop uh yesterday about machine
learning for public policy
he's been a speaker above new york r and
this conference before
it's always a lot of fun and i love the
before and after photos of him